همم مؤتمر بغداد سنه الماضيه اعادت العراق
الى حيث ينبغي ان يكون ان يكون بلدا مهما
وفعلا واجذرا بالثقه وايضا دافعا للسلام
والاستقرار في المنطق ولكن الكثير قد تغير
منذ سنه الماضيه
حاربوا روسيا
ضد اوكرانيا
لا يعتبروا
امرا يخص اوروبا فقط ولكنه هجوء الهجوم
على النظام
الدوليات امنيه همم
بعيده المدى وان العراق ذاته قد وجها عددا
من التحديات الخطيره منذ بغداد ولكن
تشكيله الحكومه الجديده التي يقودها رئيس
الوزراء السيد السوداني قد نجحت في انهاء
هذه الوضع يحدد لهذه الفتره المطربه فان
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو صديق حقيقي للعراق
واي يقف مستعدا لدعم رئيس الوزراء
السوداني
والتزانه
بالقيام بالاصلاحات الشامله كما طالب بها
الشعب العراقي
بكره
العراق قويا ودوروسياده من ديمقراطي يفيد
شعبه والمنطقه والاتحاد الاوروبي والعالم
واننا نخطط
لاجتماعنا على المستوى
الوزاري بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والعراق في
النصف الاول من العام القادم ان العراق لا
ينبغي او لا يمكن ان يكون ساحه معركه ابل
وكاله لقد
بل ينبغي كما كان لفتره طويله لقد بل
ينبغي ان يكون جسرا همم او يبني الجسور
اقليميه والتي ترسم بتقليل الاضطرابات
الاقليميه وهذا هو لهذا السبب ندعم جهود
الا حكومه العراقيه
لتطوير سياستن
اليوم ليس مهمه فقط للعراق لكل لكل جميعنا
منذ 2017
رنج ان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد اسهمت في عراق
اكثر امنا وقوه عبر البعثه الاستشاريه
للاتحاد الاوروبي
والتي مددنا همم مددنا مهمتها حتى نهايه
شهر نيسان 2024 ومع التركيز على تطوير
قطاع الامن وان سياده
اراضي العراق ينبغي ان تكون محترمه من
الجميع وان النزاعات او الاعمال الى
المسلحه تهدد
الجهود
للتحالف العالمي ضد داعش والتي تبقى
تهديدا للامن الاقليميه والعالمي احنا
ندعم حكومه العراق لدعميته وندعم جهودها
عبر او للوصول الى عودته طوعيه وهمم ذات
كرامه لكل المواطنين الذين العارقين في
مخيم اللي هو اللاجئين السوري
وابعاد ومبكرا في هذا الشهر شاركنا في همم
مؤتمر المانحين الدوليين في عمان
لتعزيز والدعم همم لاعاده واعاده ادماج
المواطنين العراقيين ومنذ وفقط الاسبوع
الماضي فقد اجتمعت مع همم ممثلين من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي 27
واكدنا على تعزيز السلام والاستقرار في
هذا منطقه ال خليفه وفي الشرق الاوسط همم
همم
وانها وان هذه من الاولوياته الاتحاد
الاوروبينا لكي نعمل مع كل الجهات الفاعله
في المنطقه في منهجيه همم مرحله وايضا
شامله وان الشركه الاستراتيجيه مع الخليج
قد ثبت بانها من قصه فاعله لهذه الغايه
وانما نت فخذ من العمل بشكل وثيق مع
المنطقه على الوصول الى عمل متعلق بالمناخ
والبيئه وان هذه المنطقه سوف يكون لها دور
مهم لاله تلعبه قبل قمه سيكو 27
28 اعتذر وان الطاقه كانت دائما هي
المركزيه في العلاقات في المنطقه مع
اوروبا ونحن مصممون همم بانهاء اعتماد
الاتحاد الاوروبي على الوقود الاحفوري
القادم من روسيا وبينما نتعامل مع اسماء
المناخ هو ايضا زياده همم استقلاليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وان انا قد عززنا وكثفنا من عملنا مع
الدول المصدره لان النفطي والغاز للضمان
همم امدادات من الغاز الطبيعي لاوروبا
وايضا تعزيزي انت
الامن طاقه همم وايضا التحول اسرع الى
الطاقه همم الرئيس بوتين واعتدائه على
اوكرانيا قد قد اطلق هدد الامن الغذائي
همم وهو الاخطر منذ عقود وان الكثير
الكثير من الناس يعانون من الجوع بسبب هذه
الحرب وان الاتحاد الاوروبي يساعد تسهم في
دعم جهود الامم المتحده همم
لاتعملي
او لايجاد حلول المستدامه على المدى
المتوسطه والطويل واما فيما يتعلق بالمدى
القصير المد فان الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا
تدعمه همم
في الشرق الاوسط الافريقيه بمبلغ 225
مليون يورو نحن لهم بان هذا المبلغ ليس
كافيه ولكنه العرب
على المساهمتنا ورغوتنا في المساعده ونحن
في الاتحاد الاوروبي نحن مستعدين للقيام
بمزيد بشكل مختلفا وافضل
همم افضل همم بالتاكيد لدعم العراقي
المنطقه لان
وجود عراقي اهديمقراطيه وامن ومزدهر هو
امر اساسين بالنسبه للمنطقه ولاوروبا
والعالم يجمع